we're not even finished with the
premiere Valor Tournament of 2023 and
all North American teams have been
knocked out and with the news that North
America's most beloved player has been
let go from one of these teams
everyone's been asking what is going on
with n a
hey y'all just a quick reminder that we
have emerged check it out with the link
in the description or I will cry and
nobody wants to see Liz cry I am back
baby I know it's been a while since I've
talked to you on donat me and honestly
very few things would coax me back with
such passion one a golden lovers reunion
two kanoska takashita and three the bull
that has been the ongoing discussion
this week about North American valorant
maybe both isn't the right word but
honestly I need to shock y'all into
listening to my return for those of you
who don't know what I'm talking about
the VCT lock-in tournament has been
going on since mid-February and every
single North American team has been
knocked out Sentinels were out after a
single game EG and C9 were knocked out
after two and NRG and 100 thieves held
on for three then eventually fell with
such a complete and quick exit of Na
teams from the tournament discussions
flared up once again about n a being the
worst region or just people finding
humor in the washed region but terrible
Tournament results isn't the only
shocking thing thing that has happened
in the region recently last week yay and
A's darling who some considered to be
the best in the world was rumored to
have parted ways with C9 which judging
made these reactions people didn't see
coming and are even having a hard time
believing and this news was confirmed by
Cloud9 on March 1st we had the
opportunity to pick up yay and we were
super excited because he is and was the
best player in Valor at that point in
time so you don't pass up an opportunity
like that and the fact that he wanted to
join us was super exciting one of the
big things addressing you know the role
issues that have you know been around
Cloud9 even before I came here we are
still trying to figure those things out
and so we're more so looking forward
towards the future of the team with
everything that we need to try to
correct some of these things because you
know comps are going to keep changing
metas are going to change and uh you
know flexibility and role issues are
something we need to continue to look
forward to like addressing and fixing as
the team goes on because these role
issues weren't getting cleared up we
after working on this for some time we
decided it's probably best to mutually
part ways let yay figure out you know
what is the best team for him to be on
while we sort out these issues uh
without him cloud9's CEO Jack and Valor
and head coach MCE basically said they
had role issues before they bought yay
bought yay and when the team didn't
perform dropped or mutually parted ways
with yay to continue to work on those
role issues real quick for those of you
who might be confused valorent is a game
heavily dependent on the type of
character that you play each team has a
different type of player an initiator a
controller a duelist and a sentinel and
a fifth known as a flex in a sense
deleted tweet yay's response was
officially an unrestricted free agent
role issues were definitely the reason
for me departing and the team coach
definitely agreed with me being removed
we'll address it further in a video or
stream to quote Bala somebody really
really dropped the ball and screwed up
here or as we would say in Jersey a load
and although it may seem
counter-intuitive at first despite yea's
raw mechanical Power his current
presented agent pool actually makes him
quite difficult to fit into current
partnered or challengers teams imagine
Diego's to Europe
for I don't know who it's too hard I
don't know what's gonna happen I feel
like Jack will have a hard time selling
him so he's just gonna be stuck in
contract gel they might become a
streamer straight up just like me for
real yeah I don't I don't think any of
these teams are gonna pick him up like
the na teams maybe it's like M80 or
guard I don't think those guys will
either
because like he's yeah he's in a
scenario huh all of this being said this
may seem all doom and gloom for North
America especially when our teams didn't
perform to her expectations but I would
like to propose that na is not actually
as down bad as you think this is a
single elimination tournament every game
is do or die and it's a whole new meta
with new teams that can be exciting but
it also can be pretty unforgiving had
energy won the 1618 overtime on their
final map against loud they would have
been the team that qualified instead but
I might be cherry picking the best team
in North America so what about the other
n a teams C9 be my boys paper Rex in a
pretty dominant fashion and then faced
and lost to an incredibly strong DRX
another team that is qualified EG lost
Italian sports in very close maps and
again sentinel's lost to an incredibly
strong fanatic your reminder that durka
went Dirka mode going plus 20. again
that was just one match you have a
whopping sample size of one to base your
claims of Sentinel on and the fact that
this massive International Tournament is
single elimination has been a pretty big
point of contention within the community
especially from the teams three na teams
are already out did you expect more out
of those teams do you think it puts more
pressure on Sentinels and hundred
thieves to go far in this tournament
uh I think it's an unfair question given
the ridiculous format that we're kind of
competing in here I mean half of the
teams are going home before you even
play a match so yeah I mean there's
going to be any teams that went home
unless they went all the way in their
side of the bracket former Sentinels
analyst weltis made a good thread back
in January talking about the randomness
or in smart people words variants of the
game that is valorent and why a single
elimination isn't the way to go at the
highest level he said a better team can
simply lose because these variables
swing the wrong way a few too many times
that sucks for the teams but also for
the viewers you want to know that the
teams that reach the final stages of the
tournament are the best of them there is
an argument that this format doesn't
actually allow a fair chance for that to
happen the global head of Valor and
Esports leofria actually went into the
Wiseman podcast to defend the decision
for the tournament format saying that
they didn't want a long tournament or
long days for everyone involved he also
talked about how he didn't want viewers
to feel like they were forced to pick a
stream if they were to multi-stream
which was a common suggestion once the
torment format was announced boards are
all about
personalities right people tune in
because they like the pros because they
like the teams because they have
affinity and fandom for an individual
it's all about their storylines and the
rivalries and who's on top and who's not
when you have multi-streams you're
forcing viewers to choose to watch match
a or match B and if there's something
really nice happening on matchup a and
you're watching matchup D You're simply
not following that storyline so we can
develop fandom right like it gets into
the way of creating those stories
so that's why I don't like beer ones for
anything I think that's one of the big
challenges and of course it also
fragments viewership which is just I
think bad but the other big reason and
this one is very specific to lock-in is
remember the goal of lock-in is to
introduce the new partner teams to the
world
if you have a match up and let's just be
honest and transparent here some teams
are more more popular than others so if
you have a pet shop with two teams in a
chat with not so yet popular teams guess
what's going to happen no one is going
to watch that matchup B which means
those teams are not getting introduced
to the World As We want to this in my
opinion is a defense that is valid for
what Leo is trying to defend which is
the production and the viewers this
format directly caters to viewers needs
of their ease of watching the games what
it doesn't defend is Leo's owned stated
goal of introducing less known valorant
teams to the audience one team being
eliminated after one match isn't exactly
the greatest introduction it also
doesn't cater to the players flying all
the way to Brazil and may I remind you
there are Stakes with this tournament
the winning region gets an extra slot
for their region at Masters there's only
one Masters this year one bad torment
could ruin a team's entire competitive
Year all of this being said let me be
extremely clear when I say and I did not
perform extremely well in this
tournament we lost we're out the thesis
that I'm trying to get you to accept is
that calling n a washed after this
tournament is jumping to conclusions
very hastily could it be an indication
of what is to come is it upsetting and
worrying to see C9 drop yay where he
might not find a home here yes all of
this is true I am fully prepared to see
na flop in Masters Tokyo I'm also fully
prepared to see na thrive in Tokyo there
is a lot of time between then and now
and a lot of scrims to play and a lot of
games to play in each league until then
I hold out hope and I defend our players
and coaches and staff because call Main
Optimist but
I believe in them
the golden lovers if you don't know who
the golden lovers all you need to do is
look up Koda abushi and Kenny Omega and
click on the video that's then like
reuniting that's a spoiler kind of not
really and cry that video will make
anyone cry I don't care if you don't
watch wrestling I don't care if you like
hate wrestling it'll make you cry it's
like it's the most iconic like they are
soul mates and I will not be taking any
questions none thank you very much
goodbye